well I'm joined by those three Romanian
citizens all living in the UK they are
Victor Speer sq arrived in the UK on New
Year's Day he was met at Luton Airport
but rather a crowd of journalists there
including some of our own and by amongst
others the Labour and Keith vas moniker
uremia has lived here for 12 years
Monica and her twin sister Gabriella
formed the pop duo the Cheeky Girls and
dr. Tommy Thomas q is the president of
the Alliance against Romanian and
Bulgarian discrimination and a very good
morning to you all I want to start with
you Victor I bet you didn't expect that
reception when you arrived here last
week have you found a job yes I found a
job but I don't like it now and I want
to find another job okay can you tell us
what you're doing right now
right now I mean the job that you do Oh
wash car okay washing cars and you're
going to look for another job what
happens if you don't would you stay here
and try to access benefits after a while
or would you go back to Romania I stay
here maybe three four months and after I
go to Romania okay Monica oh you've been
here some time what what do you feel
about the way that this debate has been
framed I mean it's a Romanian living and
loved indeed by by some in Britain what
do you think about what what's been said
about your country well I think that is
a big confusion regarding Romanian
population in Roma population there are
200,000 Roma people living in the UK and
there are only 70,000 Romanian living in
the UK and the media campaign has been
attacking Romanians as Roma and Romanian
people and I think it's a big insult
because there are so many doctors nurses
and engineers who Romanian who are
already living in the UK and they have a
big contribution towards the UK
including your enemy but what do you
think about you know what Victor said
there there's also the idea that a lot
of Romanians Bulgarians or whoever will
come here and try and access our
so-called generous benefits system but
you know I mean you come to work don't
you yes I think that the big attraction
is not the benefits
it is the higher-income in Romania the
wages are four times lower than to the
hidden in the UK so most people who are
coming over here or who will come over
here will not be we're not plan to live
over here for a long period of time just
to work with contracts construction
sites farming and to earn more money for
their families but this is the question
I want to move on to you Tommy I mean
you've just been greeting I mean you're
a coach slightly Romania right here
today morning what services do you
provide for them what does your
organization do we mainly find a fight
against the discrimination of Romanians
and Bulgarians as we have had to get
used with successive attacks in the last
years which have included even the
poorest of us as barking dogs and the
naming of Romanians and Bulgarians as
flim backs aliens by the you keep
independence party and we don't see
which is the difference between that and
the times when the blacks were portrayed
as monkeys I mean see all right that's
quite strong I mean but do you see
yourselves within the EU is being
treated differently from from other
nations whose citizens live and work in
the UK yes we see are sent by the media
and part of the political establishment
but not mostly by the British people
which are very torrent in their main
commitment to our us there there have
been some issue and some self o Bukh or
even racial attacks against some of our
continents but most of the British
people are very welcoming to us and let
me I want to ask Victor about that
because you've been all across the news
bulletins as we've seen there here you
are on a news program this Sunday
morning what's your experience pain what
have you found people must do they
recognize you from being a racist I have
problem with when I go on supermarket
all the people she look at me and she
tell me I see a little girl she said on
my mom hey this is the guy of the
television
I report hmm yeah but what is the
attitude I mean if you presumably come
across quite a few British people who
already live here mean if you about any
hostility I didn't understand of course
has anyone being hostile as anyone being
been angry with you as anyone's although
you were a Romanian girl our Romania no
momentarily all the people she I stay
with with him to speak it's very
friendly and I don't have problem we've
got to move on to this issue of the idea
you know there's a limited pool of jobs
and therefore that if Romanians
Bulgarians or whoever come here they're
taking jobs away from from British
people well I think I did mention this
before
there are certain jobs which mainly
British people don't do so there comes
people from Eastern Europe to the UK to
do the jobs which they don't want to do
like the uncle just love your victory
you came in there me and how easy was it
for you to get your job where that were
there a queue of British people that you
beat to the carwash you got in that you
got in the line first did you or was it
easy to get that job but yes because
some sample guy who worked there and she
called me and she tell me come here to
work with me okay okay but now it's so
heavy and it's it is your contact are
your contacts through the Romanian
community who were already here do you
have friends here is that yes I have to
find all work yeah I have much in the
Tony she finally she helped me to find
me another job in I like to work in
construction because I'm I have a great
skills
what is your skill to construction okay
you're doing in structure make a lot of
things I don't know because its
technical low words and they don't know
how to I mean okay that's fair enough
for me Tommy we do hear a lot though
about you know people in Romania and
other countries as I keep saying who
have greater skills but they'll take a
job just to get the money temporarily if
they move up that's you
ladder if Victor for instance gets a job
in the construction center industry
would he then not perhaps be threatening
the livelihoods of British workers there
may be a competition on the long term
but the reality is that this is the free
market and yes I cannot say that you do
not happen but most of them are taking
at the beginning as you said just normal
job and when he is an electrician and he
will have to take his documents and to
properly register here and just after
that he can do that but most of the
people are doing in this moment low or
medium skilled job most of the Romanians
mens are working in construction most of
the Romanian woman in cleaning they are
paying their taxes if they are allowed
to take the National Nationals number
there Victor saying all space tax is
quickness to Monaco Naja Faraj you keep
later coming up next what would you like
me to put to him I think that that bad
campaign about Romanians should stop and
though we should saw some positive
aspects as well about menu okay well we
shall see mr. Frye was listening
intently there so he's coming up next
but right now let me say thank you to
you Victor Monica Tommy very good